bonsoir à tous nous sommes le jeudi 23
juin vous regardez le 7 8 le journal
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition comme chaque jour nous
revenons sur votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités
mais également les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres les entrepreneurs par le
économie avec le parti politique et les
républicains hier soir au siège du parti
l'association génération entreprises
entrepreneurs associés a présenté son
livre blanc à nicolas sarkozy une
vingtaine de mesures pour favoriser la
croissance de la france et soutenir les
entreprises du territoire
les britanniques votent aujourd'hui
jeudi 23 juin pour ou contre la sortie
du royaume uni de l'union européenne
nous sommes allés à la rencontre
d'anglais vivant dans les yvelines pour
avoir leur point de vue sur le breakbeat
et suite aux intempéries du 31 mai la
maison elsa triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines a subi de
nombreux dégâts
elle est actuellement fermé pour travaux
et cela pour une durée indéterminée
l'association en charge de
l'établissement dans une campagne de
dons pour réparer le moulin du couple
d'écrivains et pour commencer cette
édition un mot de politique hier soir au
siège du parti les républicains avait
lieu la remise d'un livre blanc élaboré
par l'association génération entreprises
entrepreneurs associé à nicolas sarkozy
l'ancien président de la république
ce livre est décrit par des
entrepreneurs et des parlementaires
il propose une vingtaine de mesures pour
favoriser la croissance de la france et
soutenir les entreprises du territoire
camille lambert et patrick jacques de
dixmude vous en disent plus une
vingtaine de mesures pour défendre
l'esprit d'entreprise et favoriser la
croissance c'est la proposition de
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés l'association a rédigé un livre
blanc qu'elle a remis le 22 juin nicolas
sarkozy président du parti les
républicains
un ouvrage élaboré à partir de
discussions entre entrepreneurs et
figures politiques il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se disent même en france très
qui parle très bien mais qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils ne connaissent
pas les réalités de l'économie
mondialisée
là c'est vraiment génial andrus et des
gens qu'ils comprennent qu'ils viennent
de la médiation qui tiennent la france
qui aime l'entreprise française nous
proposons plus de stabilité plus de
cohérence de souplesse et le livre blanc
insuffle ce vent de liberté dont notre
pays a besoin
baisser les charges sur les entreprises
privilégier le numérique ou mettre en
place un contrat de travail unique
autant de projets détaillés dans ce
livre blanc génération entreprises
misent sur une hyper croissance des
mesures qui seront évoquées
prochainement par le parti continuer à
investir dans ce travail et le 2 juillet
orange et national on présentera
l'ensemble pour qui les choix surprenant
français qui se disent dans leur
prochain d'une place un entrepreneur
quand il a des moyens il investit quand
il a pas de moyens ils avaient sipa il
crée pas d'emplois une nouvelle vague de
création massive d'emplois passe par la
confiance entre l'état et l'entreprise
et les français génération entreprise
groupe de travail fondée en 2002 compte
à ce jour plus de 150 parlementaires
députés et sénateurs
depuis sa création de nombreux
amendements ont été adoptés notamment
sur l'assurance vie et la campagne pour
la primaire se poursuit à droite avec le
déplacement hier soir 2 françois fillon
dans les éviers l'ancien premier
ministre de nicolas sarkozy était à
aubergenville où il a une nouvelle fois
reçu le soutien de la maire de la
commune également sénatrice et
secrétaire départemental des
républicains sofia prime à gérard
larcher président du sénat était lui
aussi présent pour appuyer cette
candidature de celui qui est
actuellement député de paris alors au
cours de son discours il a abordé la
question du terrorisme
françois fillon a également affirmé que
la france était en guerre et qu'il
allait renforcer les actions contre
l'état islamique dans le cadre d'une
coalition avec la russie notamment ou
encore l'iran il a également parlé
d'immigration et souhaité la mise en
place de quotas annuels
françois fillon qui aussi dans les
sondages entre la troisième et la
quatrième place
loin derrière alain juppé espère
s'imposer dans la dernière ligne droite
le scrutin de la primaire se déroule en
novembre prochain écoutez le fur
pourquoi il faut changer de président de
la république
pas seulement parce qu'il est de gauche
qu'on l'aiment pas et qu' on a envie
d'une alternance non il faut en changer
parce que son quinquennat est une
calamité son quinquennat est
caractérisée et vous savez que j'utilise
rarement des mots aussi violent il est
caractérisé par trois choses
l'imposture l'incompétence et le
mensonge et wilfrid des riches y
reviendra dans notre édition de vendredi
très largement sur ce meeting de
françois fillon
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien ce soir nous recevons en
plateau laurence bourgeois vous êtes
chauffagiste plombier couvreur à
rambouillet présidente des couvreurs
plombiers et secrétaire adjoint adjoint
de la fédération française du bâtiment
des yvelines également brand membre
actif du groupe des femmes de la
fédération française du bâtiment des
yvelines on saura vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors la fédération française du
bâtiment des yvelines organise un grand
événement c'est son assemblée générale
elle aura lieu donc demain donc le
vendredi 25 juin au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à 21h alors
pourquoi avoir choisi ce lieu du
vélodrome et bien parce que en appart
on a visité enfin la fédération
d'organiser une visite lors de la
construction du vélodrome et ils se sont
dit que pourquoi ne pas y retourner
à la fin des travaux est la meilleure
façon peut-être de se rendre compte de
ce qu avait été de ce qu'était le
résultat c'était d'organiser la g alors
comment va se dérouler un petit peu
l'événement beaucoup de gens sont
attendus beaucoup de gens sont attendus
au départ nous devions être que 220
c'est à dire que les que les membres
participants de l'ag et puis on s'est
dit que c'était un endroit qui devait
forcément vibrer étant donnée sa surface
il fallait absolument qui est un
engouement et qu'on fasse partager ce
ces petits plaisirs et même découvrir le
vélodrome dont quoi les les gens qui
participent à l'ag ont invité leurs amis
le les fêlés comment les fédérations de
cyclisme enfin les sous le tous leurs
proches les salariés d'entreprises pour
pour faire en sorte que nous soyons
maintenant environ 2200 à cette soirée
qui qui nous souhaitons sera enfin nous
espérons être une réussite
alors il y aura également plein
d'animations autour du cyclisme qui sont
qui seront organisés c'est normal et
beaucoup aussi de membres donc dû me de
deux politiques élus qui viendront
également à 7 à cette soirée c'est un
moyen pour vous de vous faire entendre
un moyen de se faire entendre disons
qu'il faut il faut vraiment que que les
gens prennent conscience que le bâtiment
c'est une gomme c'est une grande force
au niveau du haut niveau de commandes de
l'activité
il faut il faut reconnaître que nous
avons des difficultés il faut également
que les politiques nous entende
mais c'est aussi le moyen de 2
de faire participer les gens des
activités sportives
quand c'est ludique on apprend beaucoup
plus de choses et on retient plus de
choses donc qui me semble que le
l'événement sportif sera sereine une
grande grande avancée alors ce sera
l'occasion également de revenir sur
cette année 2016 de faire un bilan vous
par rapport à vous vous êtes vraiment là
très ancré sur le terrain malgré les
autres activités vous l'avez ressenti
cette année 2016 pour le secteur du
bâtiment
sincèrement on a fait un très bon
trimestre 2015 le dernier trimestre
puisque nous nous savons en une un
exercice décalé et ce début 2016
commence bien pour nous mais je sais que
ce n'est pas le cas dans toutes les
structures
donc nous on est plutôt contents
effectivement salaire de il ya une
petite relance
nous on travaille essentiellement chez
les particuliers donc c'est très sain
c'est très important
les gens ont l'air de se décider je
pense que les mentions hergé et les
crédits d'impôts qui peuvent être
accordées font que les gens se lance
quand même dans les travaux et puis en
plus ne savent pas de quoi sera fait
demain et donc les crédits d'impôt
valable sur l'année 2016 ne seront
peut-être parents conduit nous
évidemment dans le bâtiment on espère
bien que ça ce sera ça va perdurer parce
que ça booste quand même l'activité ceci
dit ça reste un gros point
d'interrogation à chaque fois est-ce que
vous parlez aussi justement donc au sein
de la fédération française du bâtiment
des abîmes du projet de loi travail
voilà il ya encore beaucoup de
mobilisation c'est encore en discussion
en sql vous c'est quelque chose qui vous
interroge dont vous avez peur peur non
parce que de toute façon malheureusement
sera obligée d'appliquer
ils nous prennent en otage la fédération
travaille beaucoup pour pour éviter les
on va dire l'ailé surchargés et les
incohérences dans les textes qui sont
votées par des gens qui ne connaissent
pas toujours le terrain mais bon
je pense qu'il faudra simplement on
subira une fois de plus malheureusement
en chemin on n'est pas toujours très
bien entendu de tous ces gens qui qui
décident pour nous donc il ya eu la
grève les mobilisations qui vont
certainement un impact et les
intempéries qui ont été importants dans
les yvelines une saucisse et voilà une
chose que qui ressort au niveau des
personnes non nous avons des confrères
qui ont qui ont beaucoup subi à ceux
d'ailleurs à ce propos je voulais
préciser que pour certaines entreprises
et pour les gens qui cotisent aux airs
et si comme tous les tns
ils peuvent avoir des subventions
lehéricy peut les aider
ce seuil a pas toujours une mort le
mauvais côté du rsi il faut il faut le
souligner alors du coup ça va être un
moment j'étais en pot pour échanger
peut-être pour parler aussi des projets
d'avenir qu'est ce que vous attendez
justement le revoilà 2016 n'est pas fini
mais pour la rentrée est ce qu'il ya des
choses fait appel au gouvernement les
élections arrivent c'est important aussi
de se mobiliser sur ce sujet des mesures
qui soient cohérentes avec le terrain
c'est à dire que la majorité des
entreprises sondées des petites pme tpe
et on a vraiment besoin d'être d'être
entendus et qu'on nous laisse faire
notre travail parce que depuis qu'on
existe depuis que l'artisanat existe je
pense que les gens sont conscients de ce
qu'ils font ils ont ils emploient du
personnel
on n'est pas obligé nous mettre des
bâtons dans les roues tout le temps pour
travailler on est forcément il ya des
gens qui vont à l'encontre de deux on va
dire d'un d'une politique correcte du
travail ça on est bien on est bien
d'accord et on en est conscient ceci dit
la majorité des entrepreneurs est
d'aider les petits artisans ne sont pas
comme ça on a bien conscience que les
gens ont leur fait comment dire il
travaillait le travail dans un milieu
qui n'est pas toujours évident mais il
en il en choisit faut pas l'oublier que
les contraintes techniques
les poids et les jeux c'est pas les
travail en hauteur etc
c'est lié à l'activité artisans second
ne sont pas encore suffisamment entendu
peut-être pas assez passé on ne fait pas
confiance en fait de même que l'on
voulait faire intervenir des les
délégués syndicaux dans nos petites
entreprises c'est une aberration
sincèrement on doit rester maîtres de
nos entreprises
alors comme au niveau de la reprise
économique tu vois là récemment vous
l'avez dit vous connaissez une embellie
un autre sujet sur lesquels le quai
j'aimerais vous faire réagir
donc vous êtes membre actif du groupe de
femmes de la fédération française du
bâtiment des yvelines alors est ce que
il ya plus de femmes est-ce qu'il ya
plus de parité c'est un milieu comme
très masculin est ce qu'il s'ouvre vous
votre point de vue faisait alors ils
s'ouvrent mais il est je dirais un peu
lié à la parité parce qu'on nous demande
malgré tout dans des dans les postes à
responsabilités au niveau des
présidences de section des choses comme
ça de qui est qui et des femmes
donc bon c'est un plus sincèrement je
pense qu'on peut travailler en bonne
intelligence hommes femmes
on n'a pas les mêmes points de vue et je
c'est une c'est une vraie ouverture est
à mon avis une vraie chance pour tout le
monde alors les le prochain il annoncer
demain une autre actualité à part sa
part justement ce gros événement de
masse qui a aussi d'autres choses qui
vont se passer peut-être cet été ou à la
rentrée vous pouvez déjà nous parler est
belle et les élections à la chambre des
métiers et ça on a besoin de vous
mobilisez vous pour voter on a besoin
que le bâtiment se fassent entendre donc
surtout que les que les petits temps les
petites entreprises se sentent concernés
la chambre des métiers défend aussi leur
intérêt aussi bien que les fédérations
donc on a besoin de vous mobilisez-vous
surtout alors je le rappelle la
fédération française du bâtiment des
villes organisent un grand événement ses
deux mains c'est son assemblée générale
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à 21 heures
merci beaucoup
laurent ce bourgeois d'être venu sur
notre plateau fond et une dernière
information et qui vient de la part de
la préfecture c'est les entreprises
touchées par les inondations alors une
aide exceptionnelle au redémarrage de
leur activité va être versée par l'état
donc à la suite des événements
climatiques exceptionnels qui vont
toucher les deux france vous
et au mois de mai et au moins 800
entreprises franciliennes ont fait
connaître leurs difficultés à
l'administration
ces deux dernières semaines le
gouvernement a annoncé l'attribution
d'une aide exceptionnelle au redémarrage
de l'activité aux entreprises alors
l'aide concerne les entreprises touchées
dans l'ensemble des communes listés par
les arrêtés de catastrophe naturelle
prix depuis le 8 juin
elle bénéficiera aux entreprises
commerciales artisanales de service et
industriel dont le chiffre d'affaires a
été inférieur à 1 million d'euros en
2015 tout autre sujet à présent vous
entendez beaucoup parler en ce moment du
prg excite ce terme qui est la
contraction de britten
exit c'est également un enjeu de poids
pour l'europe car le royaume uni va
peut-être sortir de l'union européenne
ce jeudi 23 juin plus de 46 millions
d'électeurs britanniques ont rendez vous
avec lésions pour se prononcer sur la
question nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des watson une famille qui
vivent dont les yvelines c'est un
résultat important pour eux notamment
pour leur situation administrative en
france un reportage de nicolas landry
lives en remain comprenez quitter ou
rester dans l'union européenne
c'est l'objet du référendum qui a lieu
ce jeudi 23 juin au royaume uni installé
depuis dix neuf ans à maisons laffitte
la famille watson suit avec attention le
scrutin dans l'inquiétude
on est un peu stressé aujourd'hui parce
que justement on peut pas aller voter
donc on ne peut pas acheter notre vote
pour restaient les britanniques
habitant depuis plus de 15 ans à
l'étranger ne peuvent pas voter une
règle regrettable vraiment j'ai très
très déçu que on n'a pas un statut pour
pouvoir voter parce que ça nous concerne
plus parce que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
habite pas un grand bretagne qu'on
habite dans le
l'une en union européenne contrairement
à sa mère christopher watson a participé
au scrutin
la raison il est actuellement domicilié
en angleterre pour ses études
sa position est claire leur email
politiquement je trouve que l'union
européenne a beaucoup de pouvoir quand
même et on serait mieux de mieux
influencer les décisions si on à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur en cas de
brick site
les conséquences peuvent être
importantes pour les britanniques vivant
en france notamment concernant la
situation administrative
est-ce qu'on va revenir à la cape de
séjour pensa c'est pas très grave mais
c'est en en va encore plus loin que ça
peut-être il ya des questions est-ce
qu'on peut rester ou pas voilà comme la
famille watson de nombreux britanniques
vivant en france espère le maintien du
royaume uni si le choix se porte sur la
sortie les conditions seraient négociés
pendant deux ans entre le gouvernement
britannique et les dirigeants européens
nous saurons le résultat de ce vote dans
la soirée ou même demain vendredi 25
juin
nous ouvrons une page santé à présent la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines se modernise finies les longues
files d'attentes elle s'est désormais
équipés pour vous faciliter vos
démarches outils des deux multilingue
bornes libre service et de satisfaction
le point sur les nouveautés avec camille
lambert plus moderne mais aussi plus
accessible la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines se
renouvelle elle a mis en place de
nouveaux dispositifs dont un outil
multilingue les usages et malentendants
ou ne parlant pas français ont accès aux
questions les plus souvent posées dans
leur langue
une première en france on a plusieurs
langues alors proposé il ya pas que le
français est la langue des signes
français bien évidemment mais il ya
aussi l'anglais
il ya l'arabe voilà donc on a des
langues aussi qui sont utilisés par nos
assurés pour lesquels on n'était pas en
capacité de répondre aujourd'hui on peut
enfin leur apporte une réponse
le dispositif prévoit d'intégrer des
langues supplémentaires en fonction de
la demande
autre nouveauté un espace libre service
facilite les démarches plus besoin
d'attendre pour effectuer les opérations
les plus courantes comme ici à
guyancourt la cpam des yvelines s'est
équipée pour répondre aux demandes de
ses assurés le délai d'attenté trop
longs nous accueillent étaient anciens
voire un peu vieillot c'est aussi pour
nous important pouvoir les accueillir
dans de bonnes conditions de façon à ce
qu'ils se sentent bien accueillis mais
aussi à ce que je puisse avoir le temps
de répondre à leurs questions donc c'est
pour ça que l'après midi ont maintenant
leur offre des rendez-vous ce qu'on ne
ferait pas jusqu'à présent c'est plutôt
pratique ça fait gagner du temps ça nous
évite de se déplacer pour venir que pour
une attestation imprimer une attestation
d'assurance maladie ou consulter ses
remboursements devient alors plus facile
dans les yvelines 15 sites sur l'e19
sont équipés de ces dispositifs
d'autres caisses françaises devraient
suivre la métamorphose
les usagers peuvent venir donner leur
avis sur les bornes de satisfaction
patrimoine à présent la maison elsa
triolet et louis aragon a besoin d' aide
les inondations exceptionnelles survenue
à la fin du mois de mai et au début du
mois de juin ont provoqué de nombreux
dégâts à saint-arnoult les eaux de la
rivière près du moulin se sont infiltrés
dans la maison jusqu'à 70 mètres 70 cm
pardon d'eau est venu dans les musées
également dans les bureaux l'association
qui permet à la maison de continuer à
vivre fait un appel aux dons les
explications de manon la bad
trente mille ouvrages horn
l'impressionnante bibliothèque d' aragon
et elsa triolet un héritage en danger dû
à l'humidité causés par les inondations
le mobilier les archives le bureau tout
a été endommagé voire ravagé par l'eau
plus de cent mille euros de pertes sont
à déplorer d'après l'association maison
elsa triolet aragon
ici donc l'eau est montée vraiment
jusque et jusqu'à ce niveau là ici donc
à toucher les
et combien niveau des bibliothèques déjà
pendant la nuit et on les a déménagé au
plus vite au 6 mai donc ça a touché des
livres des livres rares ou des la
collection de vinyles de louis aragon ce
qu'on avait son le tourne-disque
d'aragon qui était de ce côté là on n'a
pas jeté de livres là les livres sont
conservés et on essaie de les soigner au
maximum on met des papiers buvard entre
entre les pages pour absorber l'humidité
on les change régulièrement et c'est
assez a touché environ 250 livres ici
l'annulation des visites prévues lors du
mois de juin mois connaissant le plus de
fréquentation s'ajoute à la liste des
frais une aide rapide et solliciter les
dons sont déductibles à 66 % des impôts
pour les particuliers il ya des
assurances qui prendront certaines
choses en charge l'état va nous aider
aussi on l'espère mais on a besoin aussi
d'avoir un soutien rapide un petit peu
de nos amis que ce que qu'on nous montre
un petit peu de la solidarité pour le
lieu est un amour tu de cette maison
laissée par aragon et elsa triolet et
donc le tout coup de pouce vraiment est
le bienvenu en ce moment 25 % de la
somme espérée a été récoltée dans les
premiers jours un bon espoir pour la
suite
la maison des à triolet aragon devrait
rouvrir au public le 3 juillet à
l'occasion du concert de sanseverino et
c'est votre rendez vous traditionnel du
jeudi vous en avez l'habitude nous
recevons avec nous sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif à mutuelle et demi
d'euros pour sa chronique sport du lieu
dit bonsoir à vous et michael dawson
je suis ravi de retrouver après notre
épisode de la semaine dernière jeudi dan
merci rien et je suis ravi également de
vous retrouver nous nous perdons pas en
pas l'arbre quel sera le thème de votre
chronique aujourd'hui est ce que vous
connaissez le twirling bâton alors j'en
ai beaucoup entendu parler en rédaction
je suis sûr que vous allez me plairait
sur ce sujet comme d'habitude je vais
faire mon maximum en tout cas dans cette
chronique la troisième édition de la
soirée à des champions du touring bat on
essaie d'organiser au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines ce mercredi
soir l'occasion pour nous de rencontrer
les dirigeants des clubs d'île de france
et capturé ce moment à l'aide de nos
caméras
mais avant de débriefer cette soirée
petite piqûre de rappel sur l'auteur
nous battons ce sport est un dérivé de
la gymnastique comme nous l'expliquent
le vice-président de la ligue ile de
france dominique pouliquen
c'est un peu comme de la gymnastique
rythmique mais avec un bâton
comme vous avez pu le voir quand vous
allez voir ce soir c'est un sport
artistique gymnique et qui demande
beaucoup de physique et beaucoup de
dextérité
on l'a vu michael sur les images ça
c'est spectaculaire intense et très
artistique je vous avoue florennes que
j'aurais pu me lancer mais bon on ne
sait jamais ce sont des athlètes de haut
niveau ce gala a réuni les meilleurs
tout à l'heure dite de france au total
ils étaient plus de 120 venus de huit
clubs franciliens le niveau était donc
très relevé en fait on a des finalistes
uniquement des finalistes du championnat
de france nationale 1 et nationales à
élite dans toutes les catégories
quasiment que ce soit en solo duo ou
équipe on a également des membres du
team france qui sont là on a des
éléments qui sont sélectionnés pour la
coupe d'europe en france au mois de
juillet et surtout on a quelques à tête
qui sont et champion de france est
sélectionné pour les championnats du
monde au mois d'août qui ont en suède
qui sont là ce soir et qui nous font
l'honneur de nous montrer leur
prestation et a partagé avec nous il y
avait donc des champions de france et
peut-être des futurs médaillés aux
championnats du monde en suède c'est le
cas de maïs camus du club d'andrésy pour
arriver à ce niveau la tourneuse nous
explique qu'il faut de la patience et
mettre les bouchées doubles aux
entraînements je m'entraîne tous les
jours sauf les jeudi où ça fait à peu
près 10 heures par semaine sans compter
les week-ends et donc un entraînement ça
se déroule sous forme d'abord
l'échauffement et ensuite le bateau où
on fait notre enchaînement qu'on va
présenter en compétition
la compétition passe devant des jurys en
solo en duo en équipe et on y notait par
rapport à ce qu'on fait alors malgré ces
images assez impressionnante il faut
préciser quelque chose dit elle ce
n'était pas une compétition et fière
hier soir au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines exactement
florane ses deux soeurs étaient plutôt
une promotion pour ce sport avec des
démonstrations en duo ou en solo ou en
équipe l'objectif est évidemment de
propulser le twirling dans une autre
sphère médiatique pour toucher un large
public dans les gradins ont recensé plus
de 700 personnes
c'est important parce que ça n'est que
la troisième édition
en fait quelque part c'est le tranquille
le trempant dont on compte se servir
pour sortir du public juste toi ligne
mais pour attirer
ah et des sponsors comme peut en avoir
ce soir mes sorties du public extérieur
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un format
court de deux heures un soir de semaine
on est parisien on a l'habitude de
sortir
l'entrée ne coûte pas cher on espère sur
le long terme attirer des gens à tirer
des médias et faire de plus en plus
connaître le tour d'une bâton une
nouvelle soirée de gala pourrait être
organisée l'année prochaine au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
je termine cette chronique par un
chiffre six ans et le nombre de tours
heures l'heure dans le département des
yvelines sont le département avec le
plus de licenciés en france
vous allez prendre votre licence florane
j'allais attendre un peu avant mais
c'est parce que j'ai un peu les poignées
fed mais bon pourquoi pas on pourrait on
voir y réfléchir on vous retrouve dans
quelques minutes et en tout cas mickaël
pour votre talk a pour nom tall qui est
effectivement parlera notamment de
l'euro 2016 il ce match entre la france
et l'irlande en huitièmes de finale de
l'euro les deux équipes ont pour camp de
base les yvelines versailles éclat
fonden c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir pas
mal de sport et pas mal au diabolique
joker de finale pas mal pas mal
d'échangés également là dessus je
pensais dans votre talk mercier beaucoup
à mikati va regarder ça avec attention
et à la semaine prochaine justement on
continue avec l'euro 2016 les phases de
poule viennent de se terminer en
huitième de finale la france qui a
terminé première du groupe à affronte
l'irlande 3e du groupe e dans un derby
yvelinois sulfureux 40 minutes séparent
seulement les deux camps de base de
versailles où séjournent les boys in
green de clairefontaine le match se
disputera ce dimanche 26 juin à 15
heures à lyon on écoutait l'adjoint
délégué aux sports de la ville de
versailles ou mécontents ou poursuivre
l'aventuré avec le père plus alors
formidable jouer contre la france
on est bien sûr convaincu qu'on en
entendra beaucoup parler de ce match
bon c'est un enjeu là pour nous et puis
le fait que ben on va dire souci une
petite revanche un peu 2010 donc de
france irlande pour se sortir de la
presse sapa donc c'est un très beau
match qui à mon sens venu très ouvert et
une dernières informations avant de
refermer à ce journal la vigilance
orange aux orages continue de s'étendre
20 départements sont désormais placés en
alerte orange par météo france dont les
iv
alors l'alertent cours jusqu'à ce soir
jeudi 23 novembre minuit
météo france évoque un épisode orageux
d'été nécessitant une vigilance
particulière dans la mesure où il ya un
risque de phénomènes violents localisés
de fortes précipitations sont attendues
ces orages pourront être aussi
accompagnés de grêle a fait attention
l'activité électrique est importante et
de fortes rafales de vent de 60 km à 80
km/heure sont à craindre donc la
vigilance est de mise notamment dans vos
déplacements prenez vos précautions
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je remercie de nous avoir suivis demain
vous retrouvez wilfried des riches y
pour notre jt de fin de semaine mélanie
pelletier dans le site huit week-ends
pour vos idées loisirs et sorties
quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi pour
une nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente soirée et
un très bon week end
tous